hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen heute zu
luca wird von seiner community gemobbt
höre ja ich habe jetzt kann man das
cabrio aufgemacht weil ich fahre an
kalium
[Musik]
ich darf darüber nicht lachen sonntag
konnten
könnt ihr aufhören - über meine videos
von vor 70 jahren zu machen wo ist der
unterschied freunde
warum
egal warum so sowie web mensch setzt
sich jetzt einfach mal irgendwo
abgesetzt einfach hier ab und ich mache
mir jetzt eine stein schaufel und eine
spitzhacke
stein schaufel und eine stein spitzhacke
[Musik]
ich habe den busfahrer heute einen
muffin angeboten aber er meinte er müsse
auch seine linie achten
[Musik]
niemand wirklich niemand lehrer wenn sie
dem klassenkameraden vor einem etwas
erklären die wahrheit ja auf deutsch
gibt es den ganzen apparat leider so gut
es war gut und kreativ
zum ersten mal heute was motiviert dich
jeden morgen aufzustehen meistens dass
ich aufs klo muss egal wo programm tier
diese ganzen alten bilder von mir hat
gestern einen cent gefunden und ihn
heute wieder verloren war es jetzt ein
online
alter
die euch ist nicht mehr zu helfen mir
hat auch philipp gebissen und jetzt
blutet manager
dieser moment wenn du endlich in einer
angenehmen position links und seinen fuß
auf einmal damit anfängt das stimmt
woher kommt das eigentlich decker
weil das blut dann nicht durch die venen
von den adern luca beim fieber messen
ein gutes team
kreativ ich schieße einen volley ball
mit dem fuß mein sportlehrer
[Applaus]
bestimmt
gestatten das ist mir zu langweilig da
gehe ich lieber zum briefkasten da geht
wenigstens die post ab
hey
ist so groß wie mein
[Musik]
sie hat einen zettel auf dem lukas
scheiße steht und die also nämlich
endlich
endlich ist hier auch mal bei uns auch
die auch hier endlich mal die community
steht hinter mir
ich verbitte biesel so guten weg wir
sind auf einem gute
[Musik]
was kreativ muss man der person lassen
das ist jemand gewettet
es ist das heißt wenn ich kann nur den
bands live
[Musik]
o
teilweise geben sich die leute echt
klasse mühe wer ist eigentlich dieser
lucio und mit heidi aus dem rollstuhl
geschlossen das auch gut mag es ja dass
mim
nein da wo schinken drin sein das kann
nicht sein richtig
lehrern immer gesagt habe keine
hausaufgaben auf aber lesen
obwohl lesen ist eigentlich keine
hausaufgaben hallo freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einem krankheitsschub
[Musik]
es ist nicht wahr ich will hier war
pausenlos gemobbten man wlan doppelpunkt
verbunden ich dann verhalte dich auch so
so
so häufig steht da ist fehl am
symbolischen geht nicht dann geht es
nach einstellungen steht der wiener
verbunden keine verbindung
wie kann ich mich wehren verbunden seien
aber keine verbindung haben ich jede
nacht ich kann genau sieben stunden 12
minuten und 48 sekunden schlafen wenn
ich sofort ein schaf das einfach war
einfach war ich liebe das er wirklich
wenn ich teilweise - von euch sehe dass
ich mir dann denke ich dachte ich werde
einzige gewesen
ich gehöre zu den menschen die bei der
50 50-chance usb stick richtig
reinzustecken drei versuche brauchen das
ist dann auch leider die wahrheit in
meinem fall war
egal
weil es so laut geschrien das einfach
meine ukulele da oben den ton von sich
gegeben hat
es hat echt so
schon wieder der gartenschau es doch gar
nicht im film doch auch ich zwei minuten
später ich kann nicht bei filmen
einschlafen
ein kollege von mir und ich ältere of
play
oder filme apropos haare
da
natürlich auch direkt ein neues
instagram foto hochgeladen mit dem man
mich wirklich mit dem weihnachtsmann
verwechseln könnte instagram wenn das
nicht leicht dann blockiere ich euch
überall ein gesicht ist wie ein lexikon
man möchte immer wieder nachschlagen
cool sondern auch mobbing hier
dieser moment wenn du aus versehen eine
nachricht öffnet und jetzt antworten
muss
ich sag nur 74 offene wort
für eine menge freunde wer dachte früher
auch immer das ist wirklich nur ein euro
kostete
das meinte ich hole mir so sachen dass
sich dann durch schicke dass ich gar
nicht mal so dumm war früher
ich war so weit und dann wird sie nicht
was ich sagen sollte
was sagt denn dass wahrheit was sind
bäume in einem restaurant stammgäste
[Musik]
oder halt nicht stammgäste sondern
stammgäste könnten sie mich bitte um
bringen mache ich wenn dein freund in
nur noch eine karte hast aber du noch
eine ziel 4 karte hat die auf ihn wartet
ich würde nicht sagen ich bin ein fairer
spieler ich könnte den anderen leuten
moment der duft von freiheit
der duft nach curry es war
ich habe heute nach von sauer cream
knoblauch tipps geträumt wurde
[Musik]
was das denn
was ist das
sie das sind dass sie sich was
es bisschen aus wie
scheiße front lernen ist meine droge
aber ich bin stark und sage nein zu
drogen so
ich sag nein zu drogen wenn dir jemand
drogen
wenn dir jemand drogen andrehen will
mach einfach so
luca 24 schaut sich ein video von sich
selbst an und dabei fällt ihm auf dass
er die gleichen allergien hat milben
allergie hab mich auch lori
ja maniche war so in meinem rechten film
und das erst verwalter mutter kommt in
mein zimmer warum schaust du biggest
looser hast du kein online unterricht
mein mathelehrer stabil wie stabil er
war fast so stabil wie man dieser moment
wenn man nicht einschlafen kann aber die
augen nicht öffnen möchte da sonst der
einschlag fortschritt am arsch ist so
mein reden immer alle dinge von denen
wir denken dass nur wir sie machen doch
dann realisieren wir die lukb macht das
auch
wenn ihr in der luxus seid dann geht
jetzt auf meinen instagram und lag bei
neues bild denn sonst wird sich das
nächste mal direkt in die fresse
[Musik]